[Music]
welcome back one of the biggest charity
events in las vegas
is back this week in style yes we are
talking about the clark county medical
society alliance's annual spring
fashion show and rocky is live at the
wind to tell us more hey rocky
hey you guys yeah it's all about high
fashion and health this season for the
organization so i mean first things
first
we're in front of the belmont store and
we're rocking these beautiful blazers
i think we need to do a little catwalk
you ready ladies all right let's get it
let me see you walk walk
that was wonderful good job good job
where are you going
look at her trying to walk away trying
to get away from me okay let's talk
about
the auction and the fashion show because
that's what you guys at home can
actually get involved with and help
because it's for a great cause hi my
name is shirley museny i'm the president
of clark county medical society alliance
and we are holding our 20th annual
fashion
show on april 29th that's this thursday
thursday at 10 o'clock to 2 o'clock p.m
10 a.m to 2 p.m it's going to be at the
four seasons hotel
so we're yeah what can people see at the
fashion show what do you guys have going
on
of course we'll have the top you know we
have bum on
and they're going to be displaying their
parisian couture
so we're proud and we're thankful that
beaumont
is you know participating in this event
despite of the pandemic
absolutely so what talk about the silent
auction and then we'll talk about the
organization because i want to spread
the word about that as well okay
our silent auction is live this is one
of the bags or the purses that you can
get in our silent auction
so um it's good it's uh the site is on
our
website which is ccmsalve.org
or it's going to be on our facebook page
as well
so come on down and do your bids this is
for a very great cause
which is women yes we're going to talk
about the
we're going to talk about the benefit
now with sherry here so what is this
benefiting tell us really quick and
how much money do you guys hope to to
fundraise absolutely
so uh the benefit this year we're
raising money for
is women's alzheimer's in the women's
alzheimer's movement prevention center
which is part of blue ruvo and we've
discovered that
more women than men suffer from
alzheimer's and of course women tend to
be the caregivers
so this center includes everything from
treatment
to helping caregivers deal with the
issues
that they're facing and just
lessons in um moving forward and making
their lives more comfortable which is as
an organization
so much of what we focus on that is
wonderful you guys head to the website
get involved in the silent auction the
fashion show itself is sold out so
congratulations to you guys for that
thank you and i can't wait to continue
spreading the word about this i'll send
it back to you guys
thank you so much rocky what a great
cause we're gonna check it back in with
you during the 4 pm newscast
jc we'll send it over to you